H N .
GOUOE MEHINTONOFHE
ATENERAL'S REPT NDEN
N ASSOCIATE OF THE
VERNOR FROE TIME TE AS SECRETAR
HOUSINN LOCLY AND TOLD US OUT A
R  A ROOM  WAY
T  AND
INTIMATEOUG ON EAHT.
SO NOW WVE THIREPORT
D  OEY
WOMEN,ATRE WARD THIS
DETAILINEPORT.
REALLY BLYIOBUT KERPRISED ABOU
BECATH IS A MAI'R MORE ANDNDBE
ME AND OTHEROM
HANSTI AER NOW.EXUAL M
BUT  CUOMO IE MASTER
OF THE ART O KIND  VISO
SHOWS HIN OF NO, I'M NOTT
SHOCKED. >> SO, YOU KNOW,WA
PLAYED THE SOUND BYTWH H LIKE EY
UROWS SA AND T WHE
HEE GO LGEOPLE,STRANGERS.DO IE.
I THIL
ACCU TRY TO BLAME E VICTIM OFTEN
SPLITY FORN , THEIR OWN MIST
IG THATE OF THE
ALWAYS NEVES
ACCOUNTABILITY FOR W
DONE WRONG ANDAIG AND
FOR WHAT H SO
THIS I ONE MORE STEPECKNOW, IT
REALLY IS TIMES TYPE OF
BE TO STOU YOUALT KNINEAKN HWA
COIN HISWOENNEES TRYING TO NG AU
MAKE IT G WOMEO ARE ACCUSE
HERE HE IS.
>> BUTMBER
CO
MANAGERS, WHICH SMACKS TO ME OF
DO STANDARD.FIRST,N  YOU EVER
MALEANVIAI
PEOPLECC  HOLDIN
BEING TOUGH?
ALE MANAGER IS
T EMAL ED AND .
RIDICULED AND STEREO.IT IS DOIT
ACCUSED OF BEING T TOUGHI T TO
FOR ME
R  I NOT
TREATEN
HE'S N TREATING WOMEN
OT
TO BE TREATELL  WOMENT ES
E -- BLO
BE CONSENSUAL SEXUALURESANY GEN
NOT O TELLOMO RONG KNOWS
I THINK IT'S TIME ANVIS  DET
A
AND HE JUST NEEDS TO ACCEPT THAT
>> RKAMUCH O
OW I
WANT TO GO TDEMAN KATHLEEN RICE
NE PAUSE SHE CALLED ONRESIGN BAN
ACT,HE
YORK DEMESS TO D
A STEPPED UP,
CONGRESSWOMAN AND DID IT A
GOINGST.
HOLD O YOU'VE AN
YOURE
DELEOSDENT BIDENCAED RESIGN.
>> WELL,HIF YOU LKALS NEARORTAL
RESIGN BUT THE GOVERNOR IS
FOR HIM TOAY
CRITICIZE PEOPLE FOR KRIT SIS -
CRITICIZING FEMALE MANAGERS
BEINUGH BOSSES, THAT'S NOT E G I
AROUND HIMERGHCRICY AIDED
AND D  CREATING THIS
HOSTILENVIRONMENT ATEDTHIS SEXUO
THERE TW AWAYS.E
NEW THAT TH
ER
AWAYS  HNDED BY PEOPLE WHO HELP
HIM CREATED CHOSTILE WORK
ON FOR SOMETIME ALOSO THINGS AL
ENOUGH OF A REASON FOR HIMO SIG
>> WELL, I MEAN THEY LOOK HOW LG
TH.
WAAS YOUTY AS A YO DISTRICT
THASTITI PERHAPS YET,
BU W
CUOMOALRDY? ATTORNEL WORACKS TS
AGENCIES THAT MAY BE
IN.E RST IS A CF HAL OF T VTIAL
THAT WILL BE FOR T AGENCIES AND
E  DECID
THIS WHOLEHIS NEVER ABOUT G TOT
SEXUALSE ACCOUNT ELY INSTEINOR
IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTCERE
POWER LIKECUD
REPORT, READ
VICTIMIN VERDIFFRCREDIBL V MAN .
IOR PINY
RELATE TE  SAME.MP
INDIDEMEANING OF CAUSE
WELL SEXUANT
NO
MORE ST
BUT THE CAUSE WELL DEMEANING OF
RIATENORMAEDE OF BEING
E TOHAT AN UNACCEPTABLE AND NOWO
HA THE
S AST O CA
RESIGN IF THAT IMPCH, MOVEFORWA
ACHMENT?
THINK THI?
RE
BIDEN'S CAO  CUOMO
DO GO WAY BACK.
>>O O
IN AND OLF
PREST  HDE
COE VEBE
P DEMOCRATN THIS STAPRESIDENT B
DEMO IE COUNTRY AND F IG DAT SEI
RIGHT G, WILL E
AMOU OF COMPASSION FOR THESEWOMR
NGO  GOING
THROUGH TOUGH GHT NO
TR T OF THEMIC AND DO THE T ANDO
HOPE THAT THAS IMPEACHMENT PS I
HELDCCSEEMS TOO BE